hello and welcome to the take with
sophie ridge live at nine here in the
heart of westminster and what a week to
start a new politics show we've had
groveling apologies from the prime
minister blistering attacks from the
opposition a call from to resign from
his own side and tomorrow mps will vote
on if there should be an investigation
into whether boris johnson misled the
house over partygate pmq's was
particularly angry this afternoon so
there's plenty for us to get stuck into
as we bring you takes from all sides
over the next 60 minutes
you must be out of his tiny mind mr
speaker
the state of it the party of peel and
churchill reduced to shouting and
screaming in defense of this lawbreaker
well there were particularly furious
exchanges like that will bring you the
best of the dust-ups at pmq's but the
prime minister was on very different
form yesterday when sorry seemed to be
the easiest word
heartily sorry for my mistake i
apologize uh profusely i apologize once
again i repeat my uh my
apologies my
contrition been a lot an awful lot of
that so we'll try and work out if all
that apologizing has got the pm off the
partygate hook and who better to ask
than the most important people you at
home because we are going to be seeing
what your viewers panel make of it all
and
here they all are we'll be hearing lots
more from them as the program goes on
and we'll also have some top guests for
you too including the former housing
secretary robert generic labour's shadow
leveling up secretary lisa nandy will be
in the studio with us plus we'll be
talking to craig whitaker who is one of
a handful of conservative mps who has
publicly called on boris johnson to
resign that's all coming up on the take
[Applause]
[Music]
hello and thank you for joining us for
our very first show we're going to be
live here in westminster every wednesday
night
the plan is to take the political
temperature midweek and it's certainly
pretty high today with interviews
analysis and of course most importantly
the thoughts of our very own viewers
panel as well so let's crack straight on
shall we because it's been a week
dominated by the return of partygate
with mps able to tackle the prime
minister over his fine for the very
first time and at pmq's today the
leaders exchanges were furious with some
real anger on show
i take this opportunity
on the first available sitting day
to repeat my wholehearted apology to the
house
what a joke
even now
as the latest merely mouthed apology
stumbles out of one side of his mouth
a new set of deflections and distortions
pour from the other i regret to say
that we have a prime minister who broke
the laws that he told the country they
had to follow i no longer think he is
worthy of the great office that he holds
why does the prime minister think
everybody else's actions have
consequences
except his own i feel he's in some kind
of doctor who time warp but we had this
uh we had this conversation yesterday uh
mr speaker these are strange answers
from a man who yesterday claimed to be
making a humble apology
[Music]
does the prime minister actually accept
that he broke the law
mr speaker i've been absolutely clear
that i i humbly accept what the uh what
the police have uh have said the state
of it the party of peel and churchill
reduced to shouting and screaming
in defense of this lawbreaker he's a
corbin he's doing a smart islington suit
that's the truth
[Applause]
sit down i won't tell you what you've
got to say but i can't hear when you're
talking that way how can the prime
minister claim to be a patriot when he
deliberately attacks and degrades the
institutions of our great country he
must be out of his tiny mind mr speaker
we get on with the job while they
flip-flop around like beach flanders on
the beach mr speaker
well you can see it has been a pretty
punchy week boris johnson is going to be
hoping he's done enough to keep his own
mp's on the side but what about the
public well let's try and find out shall
we because it's time now to speak to our
regular panel of viewers here they are
good evening everyone give me a bit of a
wave
if you can hear me lots of waves that's
what we like to see now we've got people
from across the uk and also across the
political spectrum so it's really
interesting to find out uh their take uh
on partygate which is where we're gonna
start let's go to chloe forest first uh
shall we now uh chloe you're
conservative and you live in a small
village in cumbria you're also a nurse
so you obviously worked during the
pandemic
what's your take on partygate how
seriously are you taking it
i think it's um you know how many times
does one person need to apologize for
something he's acknowledged that he did
wrong he's got a fixed penalty notice
he's paid that notice and i think that
there's more pressing things to be
getting on with i think the question
that they're asking of boris is has he
misled parliament and actually we don't
know if he has or not we don't know what
he was thinking at the time and it's
something that the police report and
then the sue gray report
will
acknowledge and we can find out after
that and until then i think we need to
get on with more pressing matters
and then concentrate on it later down
the line because this is going to carry
on for weeks okay maybe months we can't
keep going up
chloe there we should move on according
to chloe let's talk to elissa goddard
now shall we i think you may have a
slightly different view on this uh lisa
you're a labour supporter uh yourself uh
do you think it's time to move on
i don't think it's time to move on i
think it's time for boris to move on uh
i think his behavior and attitude has
been shameful kirsten are there talked
about institutions and uh i work in
education where we have to promote
fundamental british values the rule of
law is a fundamental british values and
he's broken that and uh he needs to go
he needs to go according to uh lisa
right let's get our next uh view shall
we lots of nodding heads i can see there
let's talk to roy royal do you agree is
it time for boris johnson to resign over
partygate
no definitely not i i tend to agree if
chloe you know
we have to put ourselves in his shoes at
the time in fact everybody's shoes at
the time everybody was fumbling around
with exactly what the rules meant and i
think a lot of the interpretation is
exactly that it's subjective
those that will hate boris will always
hate boris so this could fester for
years and take everybody's minds off
more fundamental things that that need
to be concerned about
okay there you go uh roy there
conservative voter believing that
actually are there more important things
for us to be uh talking about how about
you hannah underwood let's bring in
hannah underwood now shall we i think
you'd probably describe yourself as a
labour supporter although you did vote
lib dem tactically last time round
didn't you
what do you think about partygate is it
damage boris johnson or should we be
moving on
it has damaged boris johnson and his
credibility i think if you set the laws
he's the prime minister he's the first
amongst equals he leads our country and
should set an example and this birthday
party is just one example of where he's
breaking the rules there are others
and i think if you expect everybody else
when they attended funerals not to hug
each other not to socialize
if you expect everybody else to follow
those rules he's admitted he's broken
the law it's not even rules he's broken
the law then he should resign because
it's the honorable thing to do and
he should set an example by doing so
okay right we're going to get one more
uh take from you guys and then i'm going
to ask you to get your pieces of paper
out because i'm going to ask you to
write down a word so just hold that
thought but finally
we're going to go to paul blom a
conservative voter from london
give me your view paul is it time to get
rid of boris johnson
well i think particularly is important
um
i don't think it's the right time at the
moment i think we still need to await uh
the results of the police investigation
and the secret report um i think you
know i think it's a sense of british
fairness we need to see the outcome of
all the inquiries that are going on
but i i do think that boris i don't
think bruce will be leading the
conservative party into the next
election i don't think he'll give his
own free will but i suspect that um
the tory the tory mps will um
ask him to move on and we'll elect a new
leader at some point
okay uh interesting stuff right now i
have asked you all to have a piece of
paper handy
so i'm going to just try something out
what i want you to do
is to write down the word that comes
into your mind when i say boris johnson
what word comes into your mind when i
say boris johnson i can see you all
having a bit of think you are on live tv
here so please
bear that in mind but if everyone just
write down what word comes into your
mind when you think of boris johnson and
when you're ready hold up in front of
your camera and hopefully
we should be able to read
the screen
okay let's have a look
interesting
some a little bit easier than others to
read i can see unrepentant
uh there that is uh what lucy goddard
thinks a pragmatic chloe forrest
effective says roy roya bullient hubrist
raving unworthy and dismissive
why there's some excellent word choices
there
that says quite a lot doesn't it thank
you so much really interesting to do to
get your takes we're going to hear more
from you and your reaction in particular
to pmq's
as the program goes on now the next
hurdle for the prime minister is a vote
tomorrow it's called by labour and
whether or not he should be investigated
over allegations of misleading the house
over partygate now the government is in
for a fight tomorrow they don't want the
probe
at all but number 10 they're still
worried about dissent on their own back
benches perhaps from conservative mps
like craig whittaker who we can speak to
now thank you very much for being on the
program very first program for us so
we're delighted to have you mr whitaker
should boris johnson resign
well that's what i've said this week and
that was on the back of his fixed term
penalty notices i've always said that we
would wait to see what the outcome was
and if the prime minister who made the
laws had broken the laws and in my view
he should resign
so the government i guess will argue
that
it's effectively a sideshow he's
apologized there are more important
things to be getting on with with
ukraine in the cost of living you
clearly don't have that perspective why
do you think
that the prime minister needs to go
well i i want the prime minister to take
responsibility for his actions you know
my constituents
like lots of others around the uk went
through some real hardships and
look you know the physical act of what
he's been fined for is kind of
immaterial uh because
you know it it is excuse expression but
it's it's a birthday cake at the end of
the day
but it's the mere fact that he's broken
the rules that he expected everybody
else to to uh
adhere to
and you know lots of people lots of
families my own family saw people die
couldn't see loved ones in hospital
couldn't be with them when they died and
then in some in many cases couldn't even
go to the funeral so when people have
made huge sacrifices like that it is
important that the prime minister of our
country
who is the lawmaker sticks to the rules
you're talking about you know the
personal stories that people felt during
lockdown with your own family sort of
bereavement
you all the mp for called a valley
relatively you know marginal seat was
held by labour in the past are you
concerned that if boss johnson leads the
conservatives into the next election
you might lose it over this
no i i don't think it'll come to that i
mean the general election is two years
away and as we know a week is a very
long time in politics so you know it's
not about an eye on the general election
for me it's about actually you know this
government is doing some great things
some huge things huge investment in
places like the calder valley leveling
up agenda infrastructure spend
lots and lots of things going on
but unfortunately as i said yesterday
this is like a very damp uh or very wet
blanket that is smothering that story
and we need to move on from it
so tomorrow labour's going to be tabling
this motion to ask mps to vote on
whether or not boris johnson should be
investigated by the privileges committee
about
allegations that he misled the house by
saying that no rules were broken over
partygate how are you going to be voting
well
my understanding whilst being on air
somewhere else is that the uh the
government have put forward an amendment
to that uh i i physically haven't seen
the whole amendment yet so i can't
comment on on that but my
further understanding from speaking to
other people is that i suspect what will
happen is the whole house will unite
behind one of those versions tomorrow
and it will probably go through
so at some point because the amendment
it appears is is kicking it slightly
down the road so perhaps after the su
grey report is published you believe
that whatever happens with the amendment
or not at some point the prime minister
is going to end up being investigated by
the privileges committee
well well i mean look you know the prime
minister has said consistently said and
and this is very different to the to the
law breaking that you know there's two
very separate issues here uh there's a
law breaking which is where i've called
for him to resign
and then there's this issue where there
are people saying that he has uh shown
contempt to the house of commons that's
what this process is about tomorrow
and as i said to the prime minister
personally yesterday is that look you
know you've been saying all along that
you didn't knowingly break the rules and
at face value i accept that because i
have to
um but if that's the case then what's
the issue with self-referral to the
privileges committee anyway so you know
let's just get it out in the open
and i suspect that's what's going to
happen tomorrow
um and just finally so you uh of course
think that boris johnson effectively
should stand down you believe that as a
lawmaker he can't break the laws that
would leave a vacancy i'm guessing you
don't think that rishi sunak should feel
that vacancy as he has already
accepted a fine as well
uh
you you you may or may not know but as
well as calling for the prime minister
to resign i also call for the chancellor
to resign too because he's part of that
decision-making process just like i did
when dominic cummings went up to barnard
castle uh a year or so ago um it is that
simple for me um
look uh when we're nowhere near that
point yet of of looking for a new leader
and we're it you know it's definitely
clear that the prime minister doesn't
appear to be resigning so let's deal
with that when we get
you say we're not at the point of
choosing for you leader but you are with
respect calling for the prime minister
to resign which would lead a vacancy so
who would you think should fill it uh
well uh we'll have to wait and see who
puts the names forward at that point uh
if we get to that point and when we get
to that point uh but we're definitely
not at that point i mean i think there's
10
mps on the conservative benches that
have come out publicly and said the
prime minister should uh resign even to
get a vote of confidence or no
confidence i should say in the prime
minister um
we have to have 54
so we're a it's a numbers game we're a
long way from that process and then of
course the prime minister will probably
uh win that vote anyway so uh you know
let's wait and see what's going to
happen briefly how many other mps do you
think are in your position conservative
mps uh with these deep misgivings if you
like about boris johnson continuing in
this job are we talking a handful are we
talking dozens
how many are we talking well there's ten
so far come out publicly so i i dare say
there are more uh but like a lot of
people they are waiting to see what's
going to happen they'll wait to see
what's going to happen what the
direction from the party is tomorrow i
suspect like i said earlier on uh there
will be some agreement with the
opposition parties about what we
actually do tomorrow
um and let's wait and see
okay thank you very much craig whitaker
uh there let's bring in shall we our
deputy uh political editor uh sam coats
who is on the show with us with some
analysis i'm interested to know what
your take is sam how many mps do you
think are in the similar position
to craig whittaker effectively thinking
that boris johnson needs to go well we
know that there are about 14 tory mps
that have said on the record they're not
sure that boris johnson should fight the
next election two or three times that
say he should definitely stay but the
vast number so if he hundreds of tory
mps haven't really been clear either way
they're kind of sitting it out trying to
wait to see whether or not there are
more fines whether or not sue gray the
top official is going to look at all of
this after the police investigation is
out the way whether she's going to be
damning and only then so some weeks away
will we get some sense of resolution
from conservatives we're looking at
mid-may maybe even the start of june
before boris johnson's future is decided
that's why we're a long way away from a
sort of moment uh where uh the
conservative party determines whether or
not boris johnson continues to be their
leader and sam just explain to us what
is the latest with this motion table by
labour about potentially referring the
prime minister to the privileges
committee over misleading or not to
parliament big day tomorrow two
different visions labour want there to
be an investigation by a cross-party
group of mps into whether or not boris
johnson lied the tories in the last hour
have put down their suggestion which is
that they shouldn't instead there should
be a vote at some point in the future
over whether to have such a probe in
other words they want to kick the can
down the road i'd expect a big fight
tomorrow but we'll be looking for the
number of tory rebels toys who don't
sign up to the conservative number 10
plan not sure it's going to be that
large number because i say most tourists
at this stage sitting on their hands but
labour very kid
keen to ram this issue home as hard as
they can this week to get as much
political capital out of the bit before
the local elections really interesting
stuff we'll be talking to you later in
the program sam with some polling as
well but now it is time for labour's
take they're keen of course to keep the
pressure up on number 10 uh over
partygate we're joined now uh by the
shadow levelling up secretary of labor's
lisa nandy thank you very much for being
here great to have you on the first show
um just talk us through uh firstly i
mean you obviously feel the prime
minister needs to resign at the party
gate but i was quite interested hearing
from some of our viewers who some of
them not all obviously believe that
actually it's time to move on this is a
sideshow there are bigger things to
worry about well i think it is time to
move on it's time to to deal with the
cost of living crisis it's time to deal
with the fact that there are families
and businesses that are struggling to
stay afloat and no help as yet on offer
from government but we can't function as
a country if we have a prime minister
who doesn't tell the truth we can't
function as we saw during covid unless
we're all in it together and that's why
this matters it's not a question of what
happened two years ago in a closed room
in downing street it's a question about
whether the prime minister of this
country who makes the rules feels that
he's above the rules that the rules only
apply to some of us not all of us and
whether in fact we are all in it
together and i think what we've heard
over the last few days suggests very
strongly that this is a prime minister
that has real contempt for those rules
who feels they don't apply to people
like him and that's why you've heard mps
like craig whitaker he and i elected 12
years ago at the same time as new mps
we've been in opposing division lobbies
i think on every issue since but we
speak with one voice on this it's just
simply not good enough and he's got to
go you're going to need more mps like
craig whittaker though aren't you and
more conservative and p's to back this
motion
from labour tomorrow just to explain
what it is you're trying to do uh with
this motion well we want the privileges
committee to investigate whether the
prime minister misled the house you'll
remember that not very long ago the
prime minister came to parliament and
said there were no parties it then
transpired that there were parties he
then said he wasn't aware that there had
been parties
um and so on and so on he only
apologized in the end when he was caught
he's not sorry that he broke the rules
he's sorry that he was caught i think a
lot of tourist objection isn't it that
is your own subjective analysis of that
boris johnson's uh view is that look he
he in good faith didn't believe rules
were broken boris johnson said no rules
were broken now he says that he didn't
believe rules were broken but i think
you've got to listen to people like
craig whitaker because he speaks for a
lot more tory mps than you're hearing
from on shows like yours i was in the
house of commons today going through the
division lobbies there is a lot
it depends how many tory mps can find
the same level of backbone that craig
and a handful of others have done but i
think the fact that the government is
now conceding that they're probably not
going to win this vote without
concessions tomorrow
shows that this is a prime minister in
deep deep trouble every tory mp will be
looking at their inboxes tonight reading
the same stories that i am of people who
lost loved ones who didn't say goodbye
and when the prime minister and his
allies say look this was only a few
minutes a few years ago people would
have given anything to have a few
minutes with people to say goodbye when
they lost loved ones a few years ago it
really matters and it matters that we
uphold decency and integrity in this
country
we on the program been talking quite
about promises questions we heard some
of the exchanges from earlier they're
kind of very angry at you know exchanges
between christiana and boris johnson
i guess my question is is there an issue
for labour that it feels
like much of what we're hearing from the
opposition at the minute is anger
towards the government criticism of the
government and not that much about a
positive vision for the country i mean
kirsten is two years into the leadership
now does he not need to start spelling
out a little bit more about an
alternative vision if you guys are
serious about taking over yeah i mean
what's the biggest crisis facing people
in this country right now it's the fact
that inflation is at a 30-year high and
most people watching your show will be
struggling with energy bills hear any of
those questions that promises but we you
know we've put forward a proposal to the
government which most people back you
had the big bosses of the big energy
companies in parliament this week saying
look we can't deal with this alone one
company one sector can't deal with it we
need government intervention we've said
that we could have a winful tax on the
profits of big energy companies we could
knock hundreds of pounds of people's
energy bills by doing it and put money
back in people's pockets but if you're
talking there is an interesting security
this is thinking about the the
monumental
uh crisis that we face in terms of the
cost of living in terms of energy
windfall tax on all companies we don't
need to be a bit more ambitious than
that don't you think need to talk about
some really difficult decisions uh on
energy security yeah look we're far more
ambitious than that i mean i was the
shadow foreign secretary who came on
your show and said labour got it wrong
on russia
not least because we had to get very
tough not just about the interference of
russian money and politics in british
politics but also about our own energy
security we shouldn't be reliant on
countries like russia for energy even if
it means bigger bills for people in the
uk but that's precisely the point the
reason that we've got sky-high bills for
people here in the uk is because we're
taking these knee-jerk reactions in
response to major events rather than
foreseeing those events we've degraded
our gas storage capability over the last
decade i was the shadow energy secretary
is warning not to do that we slashed
solar tariffs that supported the growing
solar industry we took the axe to
onshore wind a few years ago under a
tory leadership this has gone on for a
very long time and we've been pushing
the government over the last couple of
years to take seriously the fact that if
you want to cut people's energy bills
you've actually got to invest in home
insulation which the government is
currently cutting of course you've got
to take action in the long term but this
is a crisis right now and the government
should also be taking action in the
short term just finally there's a
critical by-election coming up in
wakefield big test for labour for the
government as well
there's a lot of rumors about ed balls
coming back and standing as a labour
candidate in wakefield
any truth in it well look i don't know i
mean i don't get involved in candidate
selection that's a matter for the
members of wakefield clp i mean i've
watched ed ball's
growing infamy and career with huge
interest as many people have over the
last few years whether he wants to give
up his dancing shoes and return to
politics you know that's a question for
the members of wakefield would you like
to see him return to frontline politics
i've got huge respect for him you know i
worked with him when i was working with
child refugees and he was one of the
people in government who was very
instrumental in making sure that we got
decent treatment for those kids so i've
got a lot of time for ed balls but it's
up to the members in wakefield the point
is surely that we've just had this
appalling incident with the existing
tory mp who's now done the right thing
and stood down we've now got to get a
labour mp re-elected so that those
people in wakefield finally have an mp
that they can be proud of okay lisa and
andy uh thank you very much being on the
programme today thank you nandy there
you're watching the take we are live in
westminster up next we're going to be
hearing our question of the week from
pmq's where we give the backbencher a
chance to respond to the prime minister
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
b
[Music]
hello welcome back live to westminster
this is the take
now if you're a politics geek like me
pmq's is one of the political highlights
of the week and it was certainly a fiery
session today so here's what our
political correspondent joe pike made of
it this is pmq's unwrapped
boris johnson is desperate to move on
from the partygate row yesterday mps
were debating it tomorrow they'll be
voting on it and today labour and the
smp piled on that pressure one of
kierstarm's advisers told me their
strategy is to punch the bruise
a merely mouthed apology when the
cameras roll
a vicious attack on those who tell the
truth as soon as the cameras are off why
does the prime minister think everybody
else's actions have consequences
except his own would the prime minister
like to take this opportunity to
apologize
for slandering the archbishop of the
church of england
labour's accusation here boris johnson
may have said sorry in public yesterday
but privately in a meeting of tory mps
he was less effusive and reportedly
criticized
the archbishop of canterbury for
questioning the government's rwanda
immigration policy the pm hit back
i feel he's in some kind of doctor who
time warp we had this uh we had this
conversation yesterday he must be out of
his tiny mind he would have elected a
putin apologist that's what he wanted to
do we get on with the job while they
flip-flop around
kirsten's questions today were shorter
and a little sharper than usual if we
analyze his language words like apology
cameras claimed resigned broke all pop
up you can see he is zoning in on themes
of character and honesty if we do the
same with boris johnson who at points
did seem a little touchy today he is
pivoting as usual to what his government
is doing for the british people
elsewhere the pm did admit lawbreaking
does the prime minister actually accept
that he broke the law
mr speaker i've been absolutely clear
that i i humbly accept what the uh what
the police have uh have said when an smp
mp suggested the pm was a liar they just
want this pinocchio prime minister to
pack his bags and go
it was a commons clerk who flagged it to
the speaker and we also heard a new tory
attack line i think he's a corbin
eastern illinois suit he's a corbin
eastern a smart islington suit i think
you'll find mr corby doesn't have the
whip
it is perhaps worth remembering boris
johnson was a long-term resident of
islington and sakir lives in camden this
whole partygate row has now been going
on for more than four months is there
anyone who hasn't made up their mind
maybe not but by keeping the story in
the headlines opposition parties are
trying to ensure it's at the forefront
of voters minds for the local elections
in 15 days time
that was uh joe pike on all the action
in the commons this afternoon so let's
find out what our viewers panel made of
it all
so first of all uh bearing in mind of
course that this is eight people they're
politically representative but it
doesn't reflect of course what everyone
necessarily believes but just let's do a
show of hands fair shall we if you think
that boris johnson won today's prime
minister's questions
put your hand up now
if you think boris johnson came out on
top
put your hand up now
i've got one person
okay if you think that kia starman came
out on top
raise your hand now
one
person
two people
say what about what about the rest of
you then the other five do you think
that no one came out on top were you
just a bit disappointed with pmq's if
you didn't if you thought they were both
as bad as each other
a draw
both as well as each other raise up your
hand
okay
that's where that's where public opinion
is now right let's go to roz uh now
shall we uh let's talk to uh rose
mcmullen a labour voter from york uh to
get your perspective on pmq's what did
you make of today's uh pretty fiery
session wasn't it ross
well i think kyocerma was right to go on
the issue of character because
fundamentally this is what it's about
it's about the fact that the prime
minister tells lies he's an accomplished
liar he's been sacked from two previous
jobs for lying and he is totally unfit
for public office
you know he told us he told the house of
commons that he was angered
uh
and distressed what was it shocked and
angry i think was the words he said
about the allegra stratton video that
was released
um when clearly you know all the time he
knew that he had broken his own laws and
don't forget that this fixed penalty
notice is actually probably for the
least of the law breaking that he has
taken part in it's only the first he
constantly deflects he constantly tries
to get people to put the blame on others
he's currently trying to hide behind the
distress of the ukrainian people
it it is sickening the man is unfit for
public office and i think kirsten was
absolutely right to go on the issue of
character because this is the problem we
have prime minister we cannot trust ros
not trusting the prime minister they're
pretty strong views uh there let's talk
to smith thakur shall we um
you are quite like
akira stanley's labour party don't you
but how do you think kirstama performed
at this today's promises questions you
didn't raise your hand there so i'm
interested to know your thoughts
yeah i thought um
labour were quite weak
in today's questions i felt like they
gave boys johnson an easy way out i
think the temperature was raised up for
them to really strike and you know uh
have some really punchy questions but
the very first question for example was
on allegra's strategy
they're asking the prime minister well
why did she resign almost as trying to
second guess that
he will lead them on to the doing
something wrong and the integrity issue
but actually the the the real question
at hand
um was um
you you keep saying get on with the job
and every time someone raises this issue
you say get on with the job what does
get on with the job
mean you comply with the law and the
rules that you have formulated are you
going to do that in a compliant manner
okay right well let's talk to tim shall
we tim wiltshire a swing voter uh what
did you make of today's
prime minister's questions session
to be honest i think it's disappointing
um
everybody seems to be pursuing a minor
issue
with partygate and there are far more
pressing matters when one looks at the
ukraine and energy and the economy and
things like that
and i suppose you know not having a
particular political bias one feels that
um perhaps the opposition are clutching
at straws um and craig smith was saying
that the government is doing a good job
and doing good things and maybe that's
why the opposition of clutching at these
straws uh and going for partygate um
one thing i'd say on partygate that you
know has yet to be in my
maybe it has been established somewhere
but i haven't seen it
within the law there is clearly an issue
of intention
now did boris johnson actually intend to
break the law or did he accidentally
break the law or recklessly break the
law
and i think that you know perhaps when
the grey report comes out and we have
more detail then we can comment but
until we actually know he just happened
to be in a room um and he therefore
broke the law that's completely
different to actually intending to break
the law
interesting stuff uh right let's talk to
roy shall we let's bring you back in at
this point shall we uh roy uh royal
conservative voter you you're living in
a in kent at the minute i think aren't
you roy um what did you make of today's
promises questions uh session you've
been quite sympathetic to boris johnson
uh so far it feels um do you think he
came out well at pmq's because i noticed
you didn't think that he particularly
won this session did you
no i think you i i tend to agree with
somebody a contribution i i think he was
allowed to get away with it he dodged a
few bullets um that he could have been
he could have been hit a lot harder
and um he had a a reasonably easy ride
and i almost feel that's because
um kierstama and labour feel that
they're running out of steam i mean
really will i say this in private i'm
surprised i'm saying it in public but i
actually agreed with lisa and andy that
we we should be concentrating on
security of our power supply security of
our food supply and just get away from
this it's basically i'm getting so bored
with it now let's just move on
okay and a quick last word shall we uh
with hannah
you again you know you tend to support
kirsten on the programme so far but you
didn't put your hand up thinking he won
was he a bit disappointing for you today
i think he didn't land a killer blue i
think he had some very good questions
but i think with prime minister
questions it's not always the best way
to hold the prime minister to account in
some ways because they're quite limited
yesterday i thought kirsten was
excellent against boris johnson who
looked very
ashamed i think he came back more
prepared he knew what the questions
would be and
i i think he i said he was a brilliant i
think he was he just was very confident
he just thought it doesn't stick i can
just carry on brave it out and and see
what happens okay really interesting
stuff just a snapshot of course but um
always fascinating to talk to you guys
and i'm looking forward to speaking to
some of you next week as well thank you
for giving up your time
now it's our regular chance to speak to
a backbencher as we pick our pmq of the
week it's the one that really caught our
eye during the session earlier and today
let's have a listen it's this one a
constituent aiden aslan has served in
the ukrainian armed forces for four
years
last week he was captured by the russian
army in mariopol
yesterday a video emerged of my
constituent handcuffed
physically injured
and being interviewed under duress for
propaganda purposes
would my right honourable friend agree
with me that this is a flagrant breach
of the geneva convention
that treating any prisoner of war in
this manner is illegal
and that the interviewer graham phillips
is in danger of prosecution for war
crimes and that any online platform such
as youtube which hosts propaganda videos
of this kind should take them down
immediately
very distressing story of course many of
us will be familiar uh with that case
now of course usually the questioner
doesn't get the chance to respond to the
prime minister's answer but we're going
to try and put that right so every week
let the mp
do that now the question that we just
had was from robert generick formerly in
the cabinet of course till np for new
york and he joins us now
what did you make of the prime
minister's reply to your question
well i was pleased with it because he
was obviously knowledgeable about the
case and had been properly briefed on it
and was able to say that my constituent
was not as vladimir putin has said a
mercenary or a spy but a british citizen
who joined the ukrainian army some time
ago has fought bravely and is now at the
hands of the russians and being treated
in this appalling way
there isn't a great deal the british
government can do
we hope that in time aiden will be freed
and as part of a prisoner
exchange which is happening at the
moment between the russians and the
ukrainians but the main thing that i
want to do is to ensure that in the
meantime he's treated appropriately and
it's frankly disgusting that he is being
paraded on russian tv interviewed by
putin's puppets like this so-called
journalist graeme phillips and that
social media firms are hosting these
grotesque videos so that's i guess where
you think the pm could
act it felt to me looking at his answer
you know
echoing your sentiments urging the
russian state to treat your constituency
humanely a lot of world words but you
didn't exactly promise that much action
did it well the one area i think the
british government could act as you say
is to ensure that the social media
platforms take down russian
disinformation and propaganda videos
like this i mean the last time i checked
youtube still have this video up it's
been viewed hundreds of thousands of
times and i say it is the most grotesque
form of propaganda where a british
citizen is sat there bruised handcuffed
and being interrogated this sort of
thing shouldn't be happening in the
first place but reputable social media
companies should be having nothing to do
with it
um
talking about domestic politics uh now
earlier in the program we spoke to your
colleague the conservative mp craig
whitaker he said that he thinks boris
johnson needs to step down because if
you make the law you can't then break
the law
he's right isn't he
i take a different view to craig i mean
he's a valued friend and colleague of
mine but i do think that boris johnson
is the right person to be leading the
country i can't see
at a time when there are such big issues
like a european war like a emerging and
escalating economic crisis
that we would want to get into the
territory of a leadership election and
contemplating a changing leader that
doesn't seem to me to be in the next
i've heard this argument before that you
know we're in a time of war so we can't
change the leader i mean we aren't at
what are we obviously ukraine is at war
and but also there's president for
changing prime minister and leader even
when we are at war we changed leader
during world war one twice during world
war ii well i think there's a with
respect quite poor comparisons the times
that prime ministers have resigned in
the past have generally been because
there's been a catastrophic failure of
the government's central policy like
never changing like in the eden some
people
some people would say that there's been
a catastrophic uh failure of public
confidence in the prime minister because
as we heard from a panelist quite a lot
of them think that he's lied
well your panel was actually quite split
from the conversation i heard and that
there were certainly people on the panel
who felt that this has been a sorry
episode that it's something that should
clearly not have happened however there
are very important issues facing the
country and
it sounded to me as if some of your
panelists at least wanted us
to move on and concentrate on those big
issues that's how i feel i think that
politics now needs to be focusing on the
cost of living above all and in the war
in ukraine as well these are issues of
huge importance and we should be careful
about being diverted that's not to say
that we should trivialize what's
happened i think the prime minister is
embarrassed
mortified by what's happened he's
apologized to parliament i think that
was the right thing to do but i do now
think as a member of parliament i'm not
a member of the government that these
issues that the public really need to be
front and center now are the costs of
living are ukraine are those issues of
huge national and international
importance you say you think the prime
minister's mortified is that from the
public statements he's made or have you
heard anything from him privately or not
yeah i've spoken to him privately and of
course i've listened to the various
public statements that he's made did you
ask him for reassurances then
i have asked him for reassurances there
is no way he would want this to have
happened he feels extremely embarrassed
that it has
i don't think that he would have
knowingly breached the rules he didn't
think that he was breaking the rules at
the time
the rules that he created well the
incident that we know most about the one
that he's received the fixed penalty
notice for you do have to remember that
downing street themselves briefed out
information about that in the days
immediately following almost two years
ago so at the time they didn't think
that they were in breach of the rules
that's not to justify it because i think
that it was a mistake and shouldn't have
happened but it does give you a sense
that
the prime minister was not setting out
to break his own rules this was i think
an honest mistake what i think is most
important now is that he does apologize
and that we focus on the big issues
quickly um labour of course tabling a
motion tomorrow to say that the
privileges committee should investigate
uh whether or not the prime minister
misled the house and would you support
that investigation
well the first thing is that the
government is actually tabling an
amendment to that which means that there
will be an opportunity to vote on this
as a member of parliament once we're
equipped with the final report by sue
gray and i think most importantly of all
the final verdict of the police as to
whether any further fixed penalty
notices are served so i i would urge
colleagues to wait
and to vote however they wish to once
they're equipped with the full facts i
do think there should be quite a high
threshold before you uh create one of
these investigations they're extremely
rare very few of these have happened i
can't think of a precedent whilst i've
been a member of parliament and so we
shouldn't do this for incidents which
are relatively minor of which i think in
fairness the one for which the prime
minister has been served a fixed penalty
notice is it may be that when we're
equipped with the full facts on the sue
grey report that we change our mind or i
change my mind and there is actually a
case to have a full investigation by the
privileges committee but it sounds to me
as if the government has come with a
perfectly reasonable answer at the
moment which is let's have that debate
when we all know what the true facts are
okay robert jenner thank you very much
for being on the program uh today you're
watching the take we are live in
westminster up next we are going to be
doing some post-match analysis with our
deputy political editor
[Music]
just
[Music]
it's such a fantastically catchy tune
and the words are lovely and they just
express everybody's feelings for the
queen uh in this amazing 70th
anniversary year of her reign
and it's an outpouring of love and
appreciation for a woman who's
completely devoted her life to this
country and there's so many different
wonderful sounds in this in this piece
as you saw there we've got the london
community gospel choir the wonderful
rodney clark
we've also got maori singers and hindu
singers and a wonderful south african
singer and all the instruments that go
with those countries because it's meant
to encompass the whole commonwealth this
piece and we're all saying the same
thing we thank you from our hearts
it's our way of saying thank you to the
queen for being who she is it has just
been so fantastic and when i sat down to
actually envision the project i had a
problem yes it hadn't fit 70 years of
reign in 96 years of a life into four
minutes of song that's what we do it so
it's been a process it's using the
history it's working with fantastic
people such as anton vandermeer
fantastic co-lyricist r
and orchestration it's just been a
process that is of love it's of respect
it's of marking what her majesty stands
for and her life's work within the
commonwealth starting with seven nations
and now ending up with 54 in total
that's that's quite a job that she's
undertaken for 70 years what you didn't
hear in that little segment there is the
fantastic lyrics that have been written
and we actually describe the evolution
of her majesty from an unblemished face
to a maturing face and visualizing that
image through song really shows a
progression of who the queen is and what
she is is queen of not only this country
but 15 in total we're going through some
very difficult times at the moment
there's been there's so much sadness and
disruption in the world but i think to
be so joyous about our monarch is a
wonderful antidote to all of that
[Music]
[Applause]
organized
[Music]
i love my job because
i get to do something that is
contributing to a better future
[Music]
hello and welcome back to westminster
this is the take
we've had plenty of takes this evening
so time now for a bit of postmatch
analysis we are joined by our deputy
political editor uh sam coats who's here
again you've been listening to all the
interviews uh today uh sam
lots on party gates uh you would have
assumed that this would benefit the
labour party how comfortable do you
think they are that so much of the kind
of political oxygen i guess has been
taken up by whether or not
this man should resign over part again
well look i was really struck listening
to your chat there with lisa mandy
because on the one hand it's clear that
labour wants to lean in as far as
possible to what is undoubtedly a
political gift
but listening to her and talking to some
of the people around kierstarma there is
a nervousness that this can go too far
they know that all some here according
to their focus groups from senior labour
politicians is carping so they're
concerned about how they make that pivot
from the attack of partygate for as much
as that has worked on to something a
little bit more voter friendly course of
living lots of people worried about that
aren't they to bring people on board who
perhaps are less bothered by that and
let's have a look at the polls shall we
this is the latest westminster voting
intention you can see
labour in the lead what you make of this
so here at the moment according to last
week's ugov poll uh we essentially have
a five-point lead uh for the labour
party now that looks quite good it's
certainly better than the party has been
that point but
at one point the tory party was down 28
points and labor was up on 41 points so
they've actually even though there's
what would seem like a gift to many
people for the labour party they're not
riding at their highest point that they
have been and if you look across all of
the results back to the general election
in december 2019 when tories won an
overall majority they've only been two
periods with la uh labor in the league
one here when lots of people felt that
boris johnson was unlocking from the
pandemic too fast and here more recently
where boris johnson's been beset by
problems over partygate now you can see
it's a pretty sustained lead but i think
the biggest thing that's going to affect
tory mps when they choose whether or not
to keep boris johnson as their prime
minister is whether or not labor look
like they can sustain a lead that could
cost the tories the next general
election boris johnson is nothing to
tally mps if he's not a winner and if
that magic is undermined then so too is
he that's interesting so in a way what
you're saying is that the loyalty to
boris johnson is predicated on him
winning elections absolutely and i think
that's why the local elections are the
unspoken test yes the police how many
fines did he get yes sue gray but those
local elections will be key uh be really
interesting thank you so much sam for
the analysis well that is it for the
take the very first show we can be back
next week and every week on wednesday at
9pm thank you so much for joining me for
the first program it has been a lot of
fun next up it is sky news at 10. thanks
for watching see you next week
[Music]
you